watch
[Music]
the salt mine and jaramillo with its brief
information on monday january 4
starting next monday there will be changes to the
coronavirus testing sites at
the hotel and casino testing site taxi
station will be open three days a
week  so far
the southern nevada health district has not specified what
days they will be open while at
the test sites of an uvi and
carmen steiner announced that they will
begin requesting health insurance information
to charge health insurance
to cover the costs of  the tests
the tests will continue to be free for
Nevadans who do not have health
insurance
and although it does not seem like the season to go to
the pools is already around the
corner and some hotels have already begun to
prepare among them the hotel in
remember shorts who announced  that seeks to
hire at least 400 employees for
the pools of all its properties
seek to hire assistant lifeguards
for the cabins r  receptionists among
other positions workers start
their work in February and work until
November for more information on
how to apply for these jobs you can
visit sao dotcom
clark county students returned
to classes and also starting their new
positions are three new members of
the board of directors of the  school district
among them is the link garcíamorales
lisa guzmán and kelli williams who
will take their oath today in
a special meeting next week
board of directors meets to discuss
the learning plan and the reopening
of schools for this school year
and the libraries
All 25
libraries temporarily closed
last month due to increased
coronavirus cases All 25 locations
will apply safety measures
including limiting capacity to 25
% List of hours and locations
available on our page  from
internet news now dotco  m
now we go with your
weather forecast a week is expected with sun and
clouds the temperatures will be
above normal today's maximum in 60
degrees have a good day I am salí
jaramillo and this was the spanish edition
[Music]